[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay
show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation
about your life and your money i am
ramsey personality rachel cruz on with
me today ramsey personality george camel
welcome george it's great to be here
rachel i know it's gonna be a good show
we had a great time last time so we'll
see what shenanigans we get into i may
have wrapped last time so we'll see what
happens on this day we'll be taking your
calls again about your life and your
money at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so let's start off
start off with lon
and st louis hey lon welcome to the show
yeah thank you glad to be here well
thanks so much how can we help
i had a question on whether to
sell i'm 71
i'm retired
and
my wife and i own five rentals
and uh i'm just debating whether or not
and everything we're totally out of debt
our main home is paid for all our
rentals
everything the rv and everything just
wonderful it would be wise to sell
just liquidate the rental property and
live off that or keep it renting i'm
kind of confused about what to do so all
of the rentals are paid for
yes way to go lon i know it's amazing
have you even taken a moment to
celebrate the the fact that you guys
have all these properties paid for in
cash and no debt
oh yeah every day that's awesome so
what's your what's your retirement look
like outside of the rental properties
okay we have about uh 650 000
investments
and then uh like could say everything's
paid for
and i have that in annuities and some
and other investments
but i guess our gross income per year is
about 115.
and you guys are still working
no no we're both retired that's all from
the investments does that include from
the rental properties the
the rental income as well as pulling
from investing
yes and social security both of us have
sold security okay awesome intentions we
both have small pensions so long what's
what's making you
want
ask to sell what what has caused that
because you guys i mean you're you're
doing great if you're you guys are
living on 115 000 which is awesome
is it just is it a headache keeping the
tenants in and keeping up with
everything and it's exhausting or what's
the what would be the main motivation
for you because it's not necessarily
money
it's mainly about retiring totally
because when you have rental property
even though i have it with a property
manager now
i still the raiders still call me
because i've been with them for years
yeah i i don't know if i want to do it
anymore i guess
my rental property are probably worth
like 300 000 altogether they're small
rental units yeah yeah and uh
but i i'm just kind of confused i've
been renting for like 15 years
different units so yeah i just acquired
these other properties about 10 years
ago
and they're all in the same community
same neighborhood
well let's walk this out on missouri
let's say you sold these all of these
rental properties
and you you made 300 000
how would that affect your income
well
uh it probably it probably wouldn't
affect that much because i kind of
figured just pulling out x amount of
dollars per unit
and and until it liquidates totally and
that would be like i'm looking like 10
to 12 years and being 71 you know i just
i just don't know if i want to keep
renting the brand exactly because i just
don't want to keep reading i yeah i get
that lot i mean i think the single
family home rental it is a part-time job
i mean like you know it i come from a
real estate family my husband loves real
estate
uh my dad obviously has a ton of it and
winston works with that so i just i know
that the headache that it can bring even
though it's an awesome investment it's
fun
um but when you're 71 and you want to
retire you don't want a part-time job so
i would be very comfortable considering
where you guys are the fact that they're
paid off everything and it's in a great
it's a great market right now in general
um just to liquidate it and then and
reinvest that some of that 300 000
i think that would give you some more
security and less headache right now and
you can stair step it you don't have to
sell all all four or five at once
you can sell one and see where you guys
are at and see at what point does the
headache go away and you may not miss
the income and you go oh we're doing
fine we can still live off a hundred
thousand dollars and we've got a great
retirement and keep investing and you
guys should be fine i feel good about
this either way but thanks awesome i
know thanks lon and great job way to go
just i just wanted to celebrate him i
know it's incredible
do you know i thought he was going to
say well i got debt on all the rental
properties we're in all this debt we're
trying to retire that's a different
situation 100
so congratulations that's awesome
awesome lawn all right up next is donna
from charlotte hey donna welcome to the
show
hey how are y'all doing great how can we
help
question um a year ago i lost both my
parents
not because of curvy within about a
two-month period but
my mom was very savvy with their money
so they left me very well off um i have
half a million dollars in classic cars
and i've got probably over a million or
more in stocks and iras and
my house everything i own is paid for
but my question is my financial advisor
told me just to go online and do like a
mama bear
will
or should i go to like a lawyer and do
something
oh
because it's it is to me it's a lot of
money sure i mean i just don't want to
do something mickey mouse and then
somebody doesn't follow it through
because i had it on just a piece of
paper yeah absolutely well anytime
there's somewhat of a complicated estate
i do think bringing in council is wise i
mean you're going to pay for it but
almost i mean so even things like 500
000 in classic cars i'm like oh gosh i
wouldn't know exactly how to like you
may want someone to kind of speak into
that not just an online now mama bear
legal forms is an amazing
company they do incredible things and
for anyone that just needs a good will
in place um a state-specific will
um this is something that they
definitely can still use but but but
donna yeah i would say
uh because of this money that's
inherited and because of the the
uniqueness of a part of the inheritance
it wouldn't hurt just to get outside
outside counsel
like go to like to a lawyer basically
because i mean i don't have any siblings
there it's just me so
and your point is yeah to for the will
yeah nobody to leave it to and i just
don't i'm just not one just to give it
to whoever yeah so and i don't want my
cousins i know how that all works too
no
i mean
no judgment i don't like nobody
i don't like anyone
got her mom's and her money and she's
good
but i mean my parents
my mom was a chiefy she i think she must
have grew up with dave because she used
to save the money and the envelopes and
stuff i remember like yesterday but
awesome she wouldn't spend her money so
i have so
yeah well it's great and i think too i
think there's a level of honoring
your mom
um and your dad both your parents their
memory and part of that i think as that
next generation of parents who have
killed it and done great and and you
know have some
money and assets to pass down is i think
part of honoring that and stewarding
that well is making sure that you're
honoring them and so yeah and i think
your financial advisors got a good head
on their shoulders so i'd lean on them
to kind of assemble that team that can
make sure that you protect what your mom
left you and make sure that legacy is is
well used way to go absolutely this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
well you can't turn on your tv radio or
open your news feed without hearing the
latest and greatest plan to get rich
quick crypto real estate inflation
single stocks
everyone's talking about it and maybe
you've even considered jumping in in
2022 because you don't want to miss
another great opportunity that's out
there
so on thursday january 13th dave george
and i will be addressing these current
hot topics and showing you the right way
to build wealth in 2022 and before we
came on the air just now tickets to our
nashville event are almost sold out so
if you're lucky you can still get a
ticket in person
uh because that's part of what we're
doing now which is so exciting of having
people live now at these events and
we're also going to offer a free live
stream for you guys
who are able to join this event building
wealth the right way is too important of
a conversation not to share with
everyone so you can go to ramsey
solutions.com
wealth to register for this free live
stream
on thursday january 13th
let's build real wealth in 2022 together
the right way i can't wait
it's been great events i miss events i
miss being out on the road and
yeah this was just we're dipping our
toes in the water we're just going down
the road i know that's right just down
the road but you dave and i we're gonna
have a good discussion i'm excited about
talking about all of the things that
people are worried about freaking out
about right now crypto inflation real
estate what do i do what do i not do
yeah how do i not get screwed what if i
could make a million dollars and it's
all you just breathe yes we're gonna
show you how to do it the right way
because there is a right way it turns
out there's a lot of bad ways
a lot of bad ways and it's interesting i
mean even talking to some of my friends
of like
why should we get into this there's an
urgency people are feeling with their
money um the fomo we talked more than
ever yes and it's just it's fascinating
to me so it's gonna be it's gonna be a
great conversation at that event so
again
um join us it's free there's literally
no excuse i know so go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth to register and we'll be live
january 13th
all right up next we have a kelly in
spokane hey kelly welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call today i'm super excited to talk to
you i um i'll try not to talk too fast
in a little minute no you're great all
right thank you
we're fast talkers you're in good
company fair oh good
um i just i've been a long time listener
and this is the first time i've actually
called and i'm just excited i got
through today
um so i have a question about a mortgage
payoff and
which direction you would advise i go um
i'm on baby steps four through six and i
have two mortgages
um the first mortgage is my former
primary residence um and i have you know
i've had a solid rental history
in that house for about
10 years and
i'm towards the end of that 15-year
mortgage and i owe about 72 000 on it
the second mortgage is on my primary
residence where i live and i owe about
168
k on that mortgage um i know
that you know you usually recommend that
you pay off your primary residence first
um but i just wasn't sure because it's
not the larger mortgage as far as what i
owe and i've been tinkering around with
your mortgage calculator and i was
looking at the interest i save if i put
more on
you know the the one that i owe more on
and i'd save more interest and so um i
just thought i would call and clarify
and talk to you guys today about that so
hoping to get your advice awesome well
it sounds like you're on the plan other
than you know having the multiple
mortgages and you know we're not mad at
you there but you're right i would pay
off the primary first and it's for a
simple reason if the bank's going to
come after someone i'd rather it not be
the place i live
and so you know worst case if you had to
sell that investment property you'd get
rid of the mortgage you've got the
equity you'd be fine i would focus on
this primary mortgage i don't i don't
treat it like a debt snowball when
there's a multiple mortgage situation
you've got a primary and an investment
property it's not the kind of consumer
debt debt snowball i want to feel the
progress now yeah you would pay off the
investment property first
but i'm still going to focus on the
place i live first and then focus on
paying cash for any future investment
properties so i pay off the primary then
the investment property and then any
future property i'm going to be paying
cash for that's my take rachel yeah i
absolutely agree and then i would be
curious kelly like what if you sold it
what if you sold that rental house i
know that it brings in rental income and
all of that but is there any
part of you that's like oh just just get
it out so that you free up 72 thousand
dollars plus you know
from what you owe on it and you can
fully concentrate on your primary
mortgage and then go back and invest in
real estate down the road
yeah i i thought about that and it's um
it's in a pretty darn good area of town
and
it's it's worth the one that i owe 72 is
worth about 550 maybe more wow so um but
i also i don't know i guess i'm just so
close to the finish line there that i
thought gosh if i have it
paid for and i've had a solid rental
history i guess i was just thinking i'm
older i'm almost 44.
older 44.
i thought you were going to say like 70.
oh i'm
i'm 44 with a four-year-old so let me i
i guess i was just looking at like a
long-term investment and how much do you
make in your valley cash flow
i make about 165 right here okay does
that include the rental income
no okay what does the rental bring in
per year um
i
let's see i'm i'm just now bumping up
the rent um
i'll clear roughly about 800 a month so
um so
i i'm i'm totally
um
having a yeah a little over 10. yeah
yeah that's right yeah i guess i'm just
wondering like is it like massive money
because it feels like to clear 800 bucks
on a property that's worth over half a
million is not incredible
um it's not changing it's not changing
your life to get the extra 10 grand a
year
but to have right if like rachel said if
you sold this thing
you would have hundreds of thousands of
dollars even after paying off your own
mortgage
right and so i'm just wondering like how
would that feel and so you weigh those
options there's not a right or wrong
here but i think based on what your
goals are you're telling me you're
getting older even though you still have
you're not even halfway there
but you've got to think about your goals
and if you say man it would be awesome
to be debt free and to get to keep 165
000 a year how fast could i save up and
pay cash for a rental property down the
road and do it a different way right so
just think through those just a couple
options think through and again that's
why i like
walking through people's scenarios in
this because you know there's not always
this
we have a ton of formulas around ramsay
and we have a lot of steps and um you
know progress that you can see step by
step which is great because that helps
people walk the plan but things like
that with her where i'm like you know
what is it gonna is she gonna be tanked
but if she keeps it no kelly's gonna be
fine she makes great money she's gonna
pay this off after her primary like
she will talk to her in four years she's
gonna be fine uh but i don't know what's
option b there's always option a b c d
and i think
doing the math and figuring out
especially something like with a rental
property if it's worth five hundred
thousand dollars she's out of spokane
i'm like what other places could you get
a thousand dollars for rent and would
that even be cheaper you know i mean
like i think that puzzle of money is
always interesting to me to kind of
finagle the numbers and not just to stay
in this kind of
this one tracked mindset all the time
when it comes to these other options
that you could do with your money yeah
and when you have a paid for rental you
make more money off the rental because
you don't have a mortgage payment and so
there's something to think about a lot
of people just go i'm going to get into
real estate investing and i'm going to
get no down
but at the end of the day i've got some
friends who are losing money right now
on the rental property because they're
paying more than it's making them but
they still feel like well this is a good
investment for us long term and i'm just
like you're you're literally draining
money yes and so you've got to really
think about that piece obviously that's
not the situation with kelly she's doing
great but rental property is not always
um you know it looks sexy on the outside
and as we've as you know as dave knows
it can be a nightmare uh especially if
you can't get a tenant or they're a bad
tenant or they destroy something there
can be some serious repercussions
consequences things you have to deal
with down the road yes and the money
you're putting back into it i mean yeah
it's it's a whole puzzle piece it sounds
fun like oh yeah we have some rental
properties
that sounds good but when you actually
could then had some bolts of it it's a
lot of work and you want to make sure
financially you're in a spot to do that
and winston and i our very first one we
got in a short sale
um
in kind of a sketchy part of nashville
and it was a small condo but we put a
few hundred bucks in it got new carpet
new paint rented it i mean you can start
small and build yes on it you guys so
doing it with cash takes out the stress
that's right absolutely
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i am
rachel cruz hosting at this hour with
very own george campbell
george fun times good to be here we
don't get to host much together but when
we do america goes wild they love it
the feedback is pouring in actually you
know number one fan of this combo
situation who
sharon ramsey that is high praise mom if
you're watching sharon if you're out
there hello big fan of sharon ramsey
myself he loves rachel cruz and george
campbell together that's awesome hosting
the show but we are taking your calls
about life and money
so give us a call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we're
gonna go to anna in virginia beach hey
anna welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help i am in
a situation with my father who took out
a parent plus loan for not only me but
both my other siblings as well and
there's a total of about two hundred
thousand dollars
in debt
yeah and in just his name
um it doesn't seem to be a worry for him
but this has been something that is
constantly on my mind since i worked
hard to get myself out of my own debt
and my name and now with the um you know
the government starting to uh start loan
payments again at the end of january
it's really uh been a a stressful factor
for me
and what's making it stressful for you
the fact that he he's gonna be burdened
with this
well uh
i never knew
that
there was no discussion between me and
him uh when i went to college
that he was going to do this parent plus
loan and that i would owe him this money
so after i graduated college he was like
by the way you owe me 65 000
wow
wow um
right and so um
past couple years i've been sending him
you know venmo payments towards it
and you know ever since the the shutdown
and they stopped taking payments we
haven't tried to do anything with it but
um
i i don't think it's right that i owe
him that money when we never had that
discussion but i'm i'm torn because
um thankfully i am able to actually pay
that off tomorrow if
i you know i prayed about it and that's
what god tells me to do but i'm not
having that
mindset i feel like this is like i was
taken advantage of you know i was only
17 or 18 years old and you know my
father put me in this very difficult
position
very much so and sadly anna you know
your story is
is common i hear this a lot even i even
had a friend and they went to go apply
for a mortgage and she had no clue and
it came up and she was like wait what
um so it is sadly something that that
does happen have you talked to him about
this what's hell's relationship like
it's
it's strained um he he left my family
when i was 12 years old but you know we
tried to
we tried to mend that relationship but
there's definitely some um you know
anger still and resentment toward like
with us mostly on my end but
even more so because i have this
financial
uh burden
with him even though it's not legally
tied to me i feel you know morally like
i need to help him out with this since
she's in you know with my siblings 200
000 a day i
he he can't pay that off and i don't
want my father to go bankrupt so
um
the conversation really always ends up
in a screaming match because
i care more about it than he does he's
on the public loan forgiveness program
so in his mind after you know the 120
payments the rest will be forgiven even
if the insurance is capitalized
but that means seven more years of me
being financially tied to my father and
i i don't know if i can do that or not
yeah this sounds like an emotional and
relational decision more than a
financial one for you you have the money
to pay it off
i do but it would be all of me and my
husband's savings
including your emergency fund or is this
outside of that
outside of that okay
i mean to me i know you can put a price
on it and say yeah that's 65 000 in
savings but to have that weight
off of your shoulders out of your life
to at least resolve your end of this
relationship and to be able to let go of
that
i'm weighing those options going i'm i
may just pay this and be done with it
because right now it feels like it's
weighing on you maybe even more than him
well the thing is to anna you're not
going to be able to control him right so
he could sit on this like you're saying
for seven more years or even if
something happens with the loan
forgiveness and it's not forgiven even
for like it
and so it there is a level of
accountability he has to have that you
can't have for him that he was an adult
when he signed this up and
um
and as harsh as that sounds it's true
i'm like he he signed this so
he knew what he was getting himself into
whether he truly could like you know
pace out the entire future of his life
no
but he's the one that said so so that
responsibility is not on you but your
name and education not name but your
education and your experience is still
tied in a relational aspect back to this
alone so i
and i hate it cause i'm like man i know
you worked hard you're
you have
savings in the bank and all of it but
but there is this level of just
as john dillon would say just mental
health of just
not having the stress not having the
relational strain and the fact that it
was your education even though i know
you were 17 and there was a lot of
manipulation in it and you didn't know
about it all of that
but there is something that you could
say okay i'm gonna i am gonna pay this
because it's worth me having peace at
night it's worth me not stressing
about my dad it's it's worth cutting the
ties is basically what it feels like and
this you're still tied to him
is the feeling i'm getting from you on
this call is that correct
yeah it's correct and i guess my other
concern is how do i
how do i actually give my father that
amount in trust that he's actually going
to use that large sum of money and pay
off
my my portion of the loan since they're
all consolidated so i don't i don't
really know how that works
well it would be
yeah obviously in good faith that he
would but you're not legally tied to
this alone and so for you this is a
moral
type decision it's not a legal financial
decision it is
hey i'm giving you this money to pay off
my loan and i'm done you can't come back
to me anymore for anything i have i've
paid my end of the deal which sucks
because i didn't even know i had the end
of the deal until after college
um but i'm gonna do this so that i can i
can have breathing room and and and this
stress be off me and then at that point
it is his responsibility and up to him
but i think from your end to the deal of
you making this decision again it's not
um from a legal standpoint it really is
from an emotional standpoint do you
think if you had the conversation with
him and you sat down with him said hey i
want to pay this off would he be open to
that
what would that turn into
i think he would be i he's totally fine
with living in this debt and i i believe
based off
his
you know expenses that i see that he's
okay with putting himself more in debt
and i you know that's
basically more than half of america
being okay with that kind of mindset but
um
i i think he'd be okay with it i think
he wouldn't understand it and he would
try to convince me just to do the
payments to do the public loan
forgiveness thing um but like you guys
said i mean we have no idea what would
happen in seven years um you know he
tries to also convince me that maybe
the fine administration will fall
through and they will give money towards
you know student debt and stuff like
that but i'm i don't plan on holding my
breath for that to happen well and i and
as we're talking about this anna
uh there is a part of me that would be a
little bit like gosh i don't want 65 i
don't enable him with 65 000 through
like a video right like uh there would
have to be i would want to see on a
computer
transferring the money train you know
what i mean because i'm like i don't
want to hand him 65 000 of cash because
i think if you can get on the same page
and he's willing to allow the 65 000 to
be paid you sit with him and you guys do
this thing together and that way you can
see it happen you're on the same page
and there's this nice
clean
a clean break in a sense if this
relationship isn't going to be sorted
out but who knows there could be
redemption at the end of the story
so it's your job to just do what you can
and control what you can control but you
need to let go of this
thank you anna thanks for the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guaranteed
means that even if you mismeasure or
pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promo codes they run each every
month you'll save even more use promo
code ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from justin in michigan i
was able to graduate from college debt
free because my wife and i worked our
butts off and lived on a delicious diet
of ramen rice and beans i have a new job
that i love and we just discovered we
were expecting our first baby i want to
sell my current car for 9 000 and buy a
mustang convertible for nine thousand i
would drive my wife's car during the
winter and keep the mustang under a tarp
we have 42 000 in the bank so i could
pay cash and have a super fun car but we
are looking to get a house in the next
year can we afford this car
what an interesting question from justin
michigan oh my
a lot going on with a little stang
expecting our first baby okay and
wanting a mustang
rachel to when you guys had your first
baby
yes let's say you had 42 000 in the bank
and winston said hey i really want this
mustang convertible
what's the conversation like at the
cruise household
well uh i don't know i don't know how
that conversation would go george i
think
i mean especially if you have a goal of
wanting a new house i mean it's nine
thousand dollars
you're selling the current one for nine
buying one for now that's what i'm
considering isn't it just a switch then
it is but they're kind of down to one
car he's saying i would drive my wife's
car during the winter and keep the
mustang under a tarp oh so the wife
would have to get a car that's where i
get i get a little hairy there because
baby
what are the numbers right james
oh yeah this is an interesting situation
if if the numbers are right and it's an
even trade
i'm just saying i wouldn't do it right
now i would wait till the baby's here
and everything's good yeah
take a beat figure out if you can handle
a one car situation you know if the
wife's at home we just there's a lot of
unknowns yeah down to the one car thing
i i mean no i mean justin i would just
i'd pump the brakes literally and
not could you can you afford the car yes
it's not a question of can we afford the
car no the question is is it a wise
financial decision for your stage of
life
and to me this thing's under a tarp it's
just going to be sitting there for most
of the winter in michigan you're not
going to be driving it as much as you
think you are yeah so i'm waiting just
to give it a go
a mustang will be there there's a lot of
mustangs to go around
keep keep the two cars figure out what
life is like with the new baby and go
from there what's the car you want what
would be the car you would buy
automotive under a tarp
literally i would never buy a car that
would happen
can i ask such a whatever question about
cars sure
we're asking the wrong guy first of all
this is gonna be dangerous
don't convertibles have
like you can get a hard top you can get
a soft top why does it have to be under
a tarp is it because maybe the snow in
michigan is just so much that it they
could damage it i'm looking at the the
manly man in the booth there's a lot of
manly men in the booth give us anything
they're giving us nothing they don't
even know i got my that's just i don't
know anyways justin
i'm not doing it i'm not saying it's not
it's just a not now it's not hey this is
a dumb idea i'm just saying just wait
till the baby's here see what life is
like and then six months after that if
you still want the mustang get yourself
the mustang get yourself the stang i
hope that helps justin baby life can
just be unpredictable and you don't know
what it's gonna be like in the pregnancy
and money and definitely not in a
convertible
in in michigan in
but hey
you do you
thanks thanks for the question thanks
for the question jason all right up next
we have heidi in boston hey heidi
welcome to the show
hi rachel and george thank you for
taking my call sure how can we help
um so listen my husband and i we want
the american dream to buy a house but we
don't want to be upside down on the
house years from now
my husband and i have saved
28
of a down payment on the house
and we have no debt
however we're very frustrated with the
way the market is
the bidding war is the rat race of it
all having to bid like
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
for a house that has
issues and we're just not willing to do
that we're not willing to
do this huge investment the biggest
investment of our lives and
come out potentially
upside down later down the road
i think that
we really need help and advice on
what to do should we settle
i mean
a lot of people have been telling us
oh why are you having all that money on
for your down payment nobody cares about
that the pmi isn't that much and we're
holding to our guns
here but they have those in boston
they're very frustrated
i'm from the boston area so i i feel you
on that the real estate debacle there
and it's happening all over the country
but especially in a big city like boston
east coast west coast and so what kind
of house are you looking at what's the
price point
um
my husband and i we bring in
we'll bring in 369 this year before
taxes
um
we're looking we were pre-approved for
about 8.50 but we're looking for more of
a 650
area we don't want to be on the very top
of our budget we want to be comfortable
i think that we have the right idea it's
it's just we don't we kind of feel like
we're forced into a really bad situation
and
i don't want to use the term unfair
because i know life isn't fair
but my husband and i work hard and
we don't
we want to be able to not be stuck in
our lives we want to have kids someday
we we just don't know what to do frankly
yes and i would say heidi anytime you
feel forced in a financial situation you
could make a really bad decision so so
anytime there's options that would be my
thing options options options now
are you going to pay more than you did
24 months ago yeah you are because of
the yeah the housing market we all know
it's just it's insane right now um but
could you guys get to a number that you
feel comfortable with and to say you
know regardless of market this is the
amount of money we want to spend and
because of that in this market this is
the house we're going to get do we feel
good about that
and if the answer is no to any of those
then just
you can pause heidi you got there's no
one forcing you guys to buy a home right
now you really i know you're frustrated
and you want a home and all of that i
get that but even if you just have the
breaks for just say i mean another nine
months like i wonder what fall of 2022
is going to be like
you guys will have more money saved up
you can see if the market at all
corrects itself
but give yourself some time and do not
feel forced into a situation because
what what is the urgency for you guys of
buying a home is it just that you're
just you don't want to rent anymore and
you're like oh we just want we just want
a home
well we've been married three years and
we live in an apartment right now in
malden and the rent it keeps on
increasing every year we've been in the
same apartment first six years now when
the
rent's going to increase again
the amount that we're paying now
would be is higher
than what our expected mortgage
per month including like property taxes
and stuff like that would be
and plus we want to start a family and
the area that we live in right now isn't
really um
ideal for that
well heidi here's what i would do like
rachel's saying i'm going to use this
time to buy me some patience and save up
even more and that's what we did when we
were we were building our home and every
time there was a delay i just went sweet
one more month to save up for that down
payment and we got a huge down payment
on that house because of that and so
that may also also help you upgrade
in-house and over time if you're working
with a great real estate agent and let
me tell you if you don't have one you
can jump on ramseysolutions.com
and find a ramsey trusted elp endorsed
local provider in the boston area who's
rock star and they can help you navigate
this weird time so that you don't get
screwed so that you're not paying a
hundred thousand over asking to get into
a house so i'm gonna do it when the time
is right but that doesn't mean you can't
be searching and trying and i know it's
frustrating and it can be disheartening
but this is just the market we're in and
if you want a house right now you got to
play the game but use this time to keep
saving up maybe you guys could put 40 50
down on this house that could be
incredible yeah absolutely and i think
that's what's hard is when you feel
forced again in a situation
that can be dangerous and and people do
that i know this isn't your case
specifically howdy but even
people they find the perfect house and
they this is the only house this is the
only house where they find the car this
is the only car it's the only car and
i'm gonna overpay and i'm you know you
make
you know you make bad decisions when
it's this very very tunnel vision and so
to be able to say that yes we want a
house we want a house here in the next
18 months so now in 18 months we'll be
saving and we're going to be looking for
a home and give yourself that patience
height but you guys are doing awesome
you make great money you got a great
down payment you're going to be great
and you have a great boston accent i
love it yes she does
live in an apartment my apartment
george thanks for co-hosting with me
today i want to thank our thanks our
thank our producer james childs and
phone screener gina sears this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsey show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsey personality george
campbell joined today by the best
co-pilot a guy could ask for rachel cruz
so good to have you
we're having a good time today george
there we go good to be here we got there
america hey give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five we can
talk about your life and your money
phone lines are open keith is kicking
off this hour in phoenix arizona keith
welcome to the ramsay show
oh thanks for uh having me and i
appreciate you taking my call rachel and
george
um
my
wife loves streaming your show by the
way
rachel oh thank you
my question is going to be a rude one uh
i am at the end of a 17-year journey to
get debt-free in october uh
the
you know
literally the lion was outside the tent
door and he was hungry
honey we need to file bankruptcy or
something needs to change that level of
desperation keith what was that what was
the debt can i ask oh
house credit cards car the american
dream right you know
you know we were we were in our 20s and
early 30s and oh you need a new couch go
charge it you know that kind of uh
stupidity
uh in the process of that 17 years you
know we did the whole ramsey sold
everything we could sell paid off the
credit cards uh got the cars taken care
of uh but you know corporation uh moved
five times got downsized got kidney
cancer
uh started a business so
we're the tortoise we got there in
october
my thing is i'm the leader of my house
for
17 years we've been running from the
lion
the line's gone
it's like it you know we have these
discussions like what's next and oh well
maybe we should get a cabin and then you
know my wife and i are both free spirits
so that's another little hiccup in this
thing uh and you know my wife's on
realtor.com looking at cabins i'm like
well no we don't want to go back into
debt so it's kind of uh we're at this
weird place where you know
everything's good on hey get out of debt
do the steps get the 529 funded for your
kids we're doing all that stuff we're
doing really well
but
there's no what's next and after you
know literally the first time
in 30 years we're dead free
i feel lost sometimes i miss the lion if
that makes sense
yeah so keith let me get this straight
you guys are in baby step seven and your
primary home is paid for
um as of our 26th wedding anniversary
this october we paid it off on the night
of our anniversary way to go congrats
keith that's a big deal and i
i and
you say that with excitement and my wife
cried and it was beautiful but i've
known this was going to happen since you
know january february last year because
i knew where the money was coming from
but once again i
feel lost because i don't have a what's
next
and yeah i never thought i'd call you
guys and say that
you know well we get this
we do get this call i would say on a
regular basis of this idea of whether
people have paid off they're already on
baby step seven or they're even on just
four five and six and they think how can
we have fun like we don't even know how
to do this
uh because it's gonna take some new
habits like you said you've been in the
habit
of
of running away from that lion and
paying off this debt and now there's
nothing and so
you guys need to sit down and you guys
need to have some goals and the goal now
is not paying off debt the goal is okay
what are we gonna do because there's
really three things keith that you guys
can do with money you can give it you
can save it and you can spend it so you
need to do all three
uh i would up some of your giving i
would
look to see what can we be saving for in
the future what do we what's our 10-year
goal what do we want to have in
retirement do we want a cabin um you
know all of those and then
the part that's gonna be tough for you
guys or maybe not you're both free
spirits but to up that spending
uh lifestyle a little bit you know a few
percentage points and enjoy some of this
as well so
it's kind of a whole formula but i would
really really recommend keith you guys
sitting down my husband and i we do this
once a year and we look ahead and say
okay in the next three to five years
what are things we want to do do we what
do we want to give to
do we want to replace a car do we want
to you know go on a certain trip like
you can start planning out and having
goals out there
uh that is what your your your what's
next that's what that will be
yeah and like rachel's saying you kind
of need to plan for the fun and for the
free spirit to do that it actually is
super helpful so you don't feel bad and
you're not out of control in one area or
another you're not hoarding up money
over here saving for nothing because
you're just you can't stop but you're
not also spending out of control and
going back into debt and making some
unwise decisions so i would split it up
and go all right we want to do one fun
thing we're going to save up for
vacation we're going to go to europe
this year we know we want to buy the
cabin okay we agree that's a five-year
goal so let's just save up to where in
five years we can pay cash for the cabin
all right we want to give this much and
that way you have a plan you can take a
deep breath and enjoy where you guys are
at this is a good problem to have keith
and i don't want it to cost anxiety for
you
it's a blessing don't don't get me wrong
but i said being the leader and
literally our focus i mean we
paid off almost 70 000 on the house just
this year to get to this point
so we've been hitting it almost as hard
now as a gazelle to get it finished as
we did when we first have a you know the
credit card debt and now there's like
nothing that's just unnerving in a way
so maybe i've changed and i'm not as
much of a free spirit as i used to be
we've trained you
well and i think you can realize too
that life is you know there's there's a
quality of life that money doesn't have
to buy like you can be content with
maybe you know the lifestyle thing is
like hey we really don't need what we
thought we needed and we're kind of okay
with that like you know you're gonna get
to a lot of these conclusions and
and i appreciate keith your um kind of
intensity and motivation of being that
leader as you keep saying you said that
we're twice in this call which is great
but i think too you know money is such a
team effort and i think you know you and
your wife have done a great job being a
team through that so continue to be a
team don't put all of this on your
shoulders
bring her in and you guys together say
okay as our family what do we want this
to look like and those conversations
once you get used to it and granted you
you this has only been 90 days for you
so you can take a deep breath you're
okay you're not you don't have to figure
out this out right now
but as you really get into that new norm
those conversations are fun as a couple
when you say wow we really have no
payments what is what's our next goal
what do we want to do and um it's a
beautiful thing keith i'm really proud
of you guys yeah and part of this is
balancing that contentment and goals
it's great to have both you can have a
lot of great goals and you can be very
content with where you're at and i think
right now figuring out that new balance
is what's important for you
i appreciate that we'll have to have a
family meeting and get our son in there
and and and
work on this so yeah that's something i
like that idea of uh having a fun goal
and maybe some more longer term things
that we can shoot for instead of just
running from something that's exactly i
don't know who needs to hear this out in
america
getting cancer getting laid off
is so much better when you don't have
credit card debt and car payments i
can't imagine how we would have made it
so get through those baby steps
fast because life gets in the way
beautifully said keith man what an
inspiration way to go man it's true
enjoy baby step 7 life it's a good one
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell
joined today by rachel cruz this is the
ramsay show open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right george you know uh we just had
a call from a guy keith who had just
paid off his house and baby step 7 and i
thought rachel
you are the person that i want to break
this news to so i have a picture of my
phone here tell tell the people what it
says oh wow
george it's a blue background thank you
for the description of an image with a
circle
but it says current principal balance
0.00
george freaking camel did you pay off
your house we did it oh my gosh look at
that and the crowd goes wild
thank you to the guys in the booth
george we did it yesterday rachel me and
my wife went down to the bank paid off
your house
we did it how old are you guys again i'm
32 and she's 31.
that's unbelievable george unbelievable
you got janelle over there clapping
i knew my ramsey family would appreciate
that it's been very sweet the team has
been so awesome tell
how'd you do it what's the hardest part
should we go through all the differences
well here here's the thing i'm gonna
i'll give you a little bit but we are
doing a debt-free scream
and i don't think now i don't know if
you may be able to speak to this i don't
know that a ramsay personality has done
a debt-free scream oh that's a good
question you proved me wrong
uh
yeah that's never happened andre james
is saying it's never happened i'm going
through all of them nope james already
said it and so this is a momentous
occasion i know
and so january the 12th the day after
baby steps millionaire's book launch i
will be
on the show with dave
and doing a debt-free scream with my
wife
20 feet that way on the debt-free stages
that's amazing george congratulations i
appreciate that you've been a great
cheerleader along the way i've learned a
lot from you and the stuff that you're
teaching and i just thought you know
what if i'm going to work for dave
and especially if i'm going to be a face
for this place and preach our message i
should be doing it and so my wife works
here fun fact for those of you that
don't know we met here beautiful love
story
and when we got married and we all we
still worked here we just were like what
if
we could get a house and pay it off as
soon as possible what kind of life could
we have what kind of options could we
have what freedom could that give us
what message would that send to other
people who may not believe it's possible
for them yeah and so that was a driving
factor it's not the only factor but it
was just one of those things where i was
like i wonder if and what if we did it
what would that be like and feel like
and uh we're still in shock i mean it's
fresh this was 24 hours ago we did this
and you paid how long did it take it
took 26 months
gosh just over two years yep it's
incredible george because a lot i mean i
would say a lot of people a lot of
people if you just go and pull them
out on the street to pay off your house
i mean i think a lot of people would say
no it's no
it's not no it's not possible yeah
what's funny is we so we had to go to
the bank to do this it's very old school
i didn't know this but you know penny
mac isn't a mortgage servicer and so
when you go to pay it off it says
request payoff statement there's no
magic fun payoff button with confetti
and so you wait you get it you get snail
mailed this piece of paper with the
instructions for wiring and then i'm
like oh cool i could probably do a wire
online it's 20 21 no you have to go to
the bank to do a wire it's very secure
so i go to our bank and say hey i'd like
to do a wire and they sit me down and
this lady i mean this is just a
transaction for her right this for sure
first another thing this is a
life-changing moment for the camels but
not as much if you've ever been in a
bank they're not exactly disney world
it's it's sterile there's no music
playing you're in this like sad little
office
and she's just like all right here
what's the information okay
is this for a closing i was like no
we're just you know we're paying off the
mortgage
oh congratulations
that's the dream
no emotion on this lady's face that's
the dream
and 10 minutes later she's typing and
she goes all right the wire transfer
will happen at some point today is there
anything else i can do for you
and we just dejectedly were like no and
i always said my wife like let's get out
of here we gotta get out of here it
sounds like an episode of cripper
enthusiasm or something yes it was very
much like curb your enthusiasm james so
uh we sell after we left the doors we
felt like we could scream but yeah in
the bank it was like this is not a
safety man i wish i had like confetti
popper i wish we would have known what
if we came around the corner that would
have been fun throw a party in the bank
that would have been hilarious you guys
these guys are out of here we had a dj
balloon i was hoping like i was like if
i had a bank i would have confetti yeah
cakes we'd have like everyone walking
like chili's like they're singing happy
birthday but it would be celebrating the
debt
isn't it funny the life events whether i
think it is like paying off debt even
getting married or having a baby like
like it's like your whole world has
changed everything is totally different
but the world just keeps moving like
everyone keeps living their life and
it's a little bit anticlimactic yeah
it was over our lunch break and we just
drove back to work in traffic just going
like ah all right back to back to work
okay but it's we're joking about it but
it does
it ha it has to feel great today
being like like you're not gonna have
you're not gonna have a mortgage payment
january of 2022. yeah nothing nothing
like is that what i mean
it is very wild and i'll tell you this
just like keith we are very
goal-oriented and so we're like okay
well there's still like a thousand other
things we gotta do we wanna do we gotta
do we wanna go to europe i gotta upgrade
the car we want another house you know
and so it's funny as a driven millennial
it's just kind of like nothing is ever
enough and so it was a great call
because it reminded me like we need to
celebrate we need to take a pause we
need to be content with where we're at
and go holy crap we did this yeah like
we need to just like hug and celebrate
and not be like all right what's next on
the agenda go that's right check check
check that off check it off will you go
to like a good dinner or something will
you go well you know what's funny we
have our ramsay christmas party this
weekend and we have a wonderful
expensive dinner scheduled with some of
our best friends here there you go it's
perfect perfect you guys were booked the
cruises were booked for dinner
so
well yeah we're very excited and you
know the nice thing is i'm up in the the
dinner budget
yeah you know what i want to go out once
a week and have a really great meal
because we can enjoy it because you can
and mostly because we hate cooking with
a burning undying passion both of you do
both yeah it's a dark situation yeah i
will say that make sure in your marriage
there's someone who loves to cook you
know i found this new girl on instagram
and she's changed my cooking life every
last month yes i've seen you post some
of her recipes they're amazing and
someone that can't cook that well
all right there you go all right well
we'll celebrate later let's get to the
phone george proud of you thank you
incredible absolutely incredible i
appreciate that john sorry you had to
hear that he's in st louis how can we
help today sir hey this they stick like
all rachel and jordan appreciate it
speak directly into the phone for me
you're breaking up on us
can you hear me now it's a little better
i just want to say thanks taking my call
congratulations on the good news thank
you appreciate that what's your question
for us
with the evolutionary pressures can you
hear me now yeah a little better
with inflationary pressures right now
would you guys recommend uh for this
four five and six uh giving back a
little more emergency fund right now um
this was everything's going on in the
world but won't you still stick to your
guns the three to six months worth of
expenses okay let me recap for those
that couldn't hear you're saying should
i have a bigger emergency fund because
of inflation and everything going on in
the world right now
correct essentially got it yeah we get
that question a lot especially this year
rachel yes and this is a big it's a big
you know piece of anxiety people are
feeling of like is it enough what's
gonna happen if i lose my job and what
we found is three to six months
is enough
and the chances of you needing to
survive for a year or two you can always
go to work people are hiring right now
if you didn't know and so the worst case
scenarios if you play them out they're
not all that bad if you don't have any
debt and you have three to six months of
expenses so me personally i would not
have more than six months
right yeah and john i would say too if
you you know if you guys are on the
three to four month then you're like man
maybe we should just put a little bit
more aside
that's totally good too i mean i think
that they're yeah six months it's it's
plenty just like georgia say you know if
you don't have an income coming in
for a reason because of a job loss you
can always replace that with something
else um that can keep you guys at flow
past six months so we're so good with
that even with inflation everything
that's six months extra two percent
inflation that we're experiencing right
now is not going to make your emergency
fund either way yeah now something crazy
happens we've got bigger problems than
emergency funds you know if it gets
apocalyptic out there seven months
versus six is not going to be the
deciding factor and i know rachel you
have a lot of thoughts about the
apocalypse but that's for another show
i appreciate the call john it's a great
question and i i want to validate his
fear that it is scary so the best thing
you can do is get out of debt is have
that emergency fund in place and don't
be afraid of work that's right and that
keeps it all secure thanks john for the
call there it is this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back folks this is the ramsay
show i'm george campbell next to me is
rachel cruz and if you're watching
on youtube or wherever you just saw a
fun photo of me holding up a 0.00
balance on my mortgage we paid off our
house yesterday and we did celebrated
and rachel was hilarious during the
break i got an email from penny mac and
that starts with we're sorry to see you
go
i bet you are penny mac the camel loan
equals paid in full that's nice that
there's i'm glad they apologize they're
going to miss you they're going to miss
are they going to miss you or your money
that's the question my guess is the
money i don't know and uh we're keeping
the debt free scream party going here
because caleb is on the line in dallas
texas caleb what's going on man hey guys
um not much just on my lunch break and
figured i i wanted to
come call and give my story a little bit
i love it man well congratulations how
much debt did you pay off thank you i
paid off 17 thousand dollars in debt i
had twelve thousand in student loans and
five thousand for a car loan wow awesome
way to go okay how long did this take
so it took me about two years i started
when i started my internship and then
immediately after i started my career as
a soccer developer i
uh basically quadrupled the amount i was
putting in to my car payment because
that was the higher interest and then
snowballed it into my student debt whoa
what was your range of income during
this time
so my internship i was paid about 14 an
hour and i was starting with the minimum
um
and then when i started my career i
started at 60 000
wow and i took the
amount that i was putting for my car
payment which was about 100 a month put
that into my student loans my student
loans minimum payment was about 60.
so i decided you know what
we're gonna just pay this off so every
month i was putting in 500 a month into
my student payments after my car loan
was paid off and
sure enough for my birthday this year i
had a thousand dollars left on it and i
said nope for my birthday this is my
present from me to me
i love that
i had myself debt-free for my 26th
birthday oh caleb 26 years old and
debt-free that's the gift that keeps on
giving that's pretty amazing
congratulations caleb great so much
great job how does it feel
it feels amazing i i mean i heard uh
some of the calls today already on the
show and they they were telling you know
they were talking about how they don't
know where they what they do now they're
debt-free and i i was kind of in the
same boat for a little while but my mom
is actually a big listener
of the show and my parents have both
been big listeners ever since i was
growing up as a little kid and my mom
said go talk to one of the financial
advisors from dave ramsey and so i i
reached out and i actually have one that
i'm going to start working with next
month to put into investments for a
house so
amazing sorry about the future
man what a sharp guy your parents must
be so proud i bet they're listening
right now
i i hope they are because they were the
ones that kept telling me you got to go
on the show you got to go on the show so
awesome caleb okay so did that 26 again
this is weird this is not normal
do
your friends are they inspired by you do
they think you're crazy like how did
your how did your friends respond
you know it's a little funny actually
because some of my my best friends um
when i was talking to them about some
some finances here and there
occasionally and one of them just said
you don't
have a credit card
and i tell them no never have and uh it
blows his mind he's like well how are
you building your credit and i was like
i
didn't need to i just pay for it upfront
with cash and he he just couldn't wrap
his head around it and so to me it was
never a foreign concept because you know
my parents again growing up with dave
ramsey always taught us
you don't get a credit card because you
don't have the money
so
the concept was get the money and then
you can get what you want
wow
brilliant if only all of america thought
that way
way to go so what are you gonna do now
you're 26 you have no debt what's next
for you
so um right now i'm actually working on
myself um
i i ended up getting a raise this year
and i decided to spend that raise on
finishing off paying off my debt and i
actually hired one of my friends as my
nutritionist so i've been working on
myself financially and physically and
just trying to better my life here and
there as much as i can and
now my next goal for next year is to put
in the savings for a house and working
on the rest of my future wow
caleb you're amazing this is incredible
absolutely i love how
debt payoff and getting a hold of your
money can bleed into other areas of life
and you go what else can i improve in oh
yeah it gives you that incredible that
motivation to say oh my gosh okay well i
work on this and this like i can do it
gives you hope that you can actually
change your life because you did
so it's amazing so caleb talk to that
maybe 24 year old who's sitting there
with 17 000 50 000 student loan debt car
payments they're living off credit cards
they're getting their rewards they're
building their credit score life is
normal what would you tell that person
you know
i would have to say
start getting out of it now little by
little as much as you can put in
you know all the things that you you
think you can't live without think can
you really not live without them or are
they just a luxury item in your life
and if they're not something necessary
start getting rid of that debt it feels
so nice to go day by day living life
coming home and not having to worry
about oh shoot did i forget any kind of
payment did i forget to pay off this
excuse me this debt this loan
and
it's a big life changer it changes your
future it changes how you view
everything around you your life and uh
it's an inspiration honestly it just it
makes you want to help other people to
feel the exact same way
man beautifully said yeah it's
contagious for sure when you when you
taste that freedom and you think wow i
don't owe anyone anything
it changes it changes everything and and
i can totally see and understand that
idea of wanting wanting to help other
people in it so caleb what would you say
is is the key to getting out of debt
what's the one thing
that kept you motivated motivated and
kept you on the winning track
you know
i would have to say
to make the best of your opportunities
um for me especially since most of my
my debt was in student loans
over the pandemic you know things were
really hard just all around with
everything
a lot of people started getting really
high depression but
even though there was all this bad stuff
happening around you know there was
always a silver lining and for me the
uh
student loans and student debt had
no interest for over a year
and so for me i took that opportunity
and i you know i was snowballing as much
as i could didn't have to pay interest
on my loans and so even when things are
looking bad even if there's you know a
literal pandemic in the world
find a silver lining find some sort of
positivity make the most of what you can
and just take the lead man caleb you are
wise beyond your years man we're pumped
for you proud of you we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires an advanced
reader's copy for you uh to celebrate
because that's the next step in your
journey and we're also going to send you
a copy of the total money makeover that
you can pass along to another 24 year
old 25 year old maybe one of your
buddies who goes how'd you do this man
and you can give that to them you ready
for this caleb
absolutely all right we've got caleb
from dallas texas 17 000 paid off in two
years making 15 000 up to 60 000
quadrupled his income count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two
one
i'm jet-free
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
that's what it's amazing i feel good
about this next generation rachel i do
too i have i have at least the ones that
call into this show and do their free
screening
that's incredible though i mean there is
there is something to be said about
getting it early and that's one thing
people say around here all the times i
wish i had had this when i was younger
if only i had known this
in my 20s if i had only known this in
high school i would have made a
different decision with college right so
it's it's that kind of i wish i had
and when you hear especially younger
people do it you think man their future
is so bright yeah it's so bright it
starts with the parents i mean you hear
you heard him say yeah my parents are
the ones who got me onto this more is
caught and taught do this stuff guys
this will change your family tree change
generations to come it is so so worth it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
paying off debt is smart saving and
investing is smart but there's one key
to winning with money that people
overlook all the time that's protecting
your finances from emergencies that's
where insurance comes into play now
there are 10 kinds of insurance coverage
you might need based on what your life
looks like today and we've built an
incredible tool called the coverage
checkup to show you exactly which types
you need to add drop or adjust we'll
even rank your coverage list by
importance email it to you and connect
you with ramsey trusted insurance
providers so you can get your plan in
place fast
seriously this could be the most
important five minutes you spend today
donald wrote in and i like how he puts
this
for anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it now you never know when
something will happen and you never want
to leave your family in a bad situation
go and visit ramseysolutions.com
checkup today don't let an emergency
sneak up on you protect your family's
future now
well rachel it's that time of year in a
few weeks we are going to be doing a
special giving edition of the ramsey
show it's coming up next week and we
want to hear stories from you our
listeners about how you have given
generously this season
maybe you've tipped a waitress a hundred
bucks or bought a thanksgiving dinner
for a family who couldn't afford one
maybe you've blessed someone in need by
giving them a car or maybe you've been
on the receiving end and had your life
changed by someone who gave generously
to you we want to hear from you just go
to ramseysolutions.com
ask and put giving in the subject line
and share your story we do this every
year at christmas time and it's one of
our most popular shows one of my
favorite shows it's inspiring it really
gets me in the christmas spirit it's
coming up december 22nd so go ahead and
start sending in your stories of giving
today and let's celebrate living like no
one else so you can give like no one
else open phones this hour the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm george campbell joined today by
ramsey personality and best-selling
author rachel cruz and we are taking
your calls matt joins us in modesto
california matt welcome to the ramsay
show
hey how you guys doing great how can we
help
um yeah so i have a little bit of a car
situation
given this current market uh i'm able to
have my car paid off
uh currently i owe about 18 000 on it
um the only issue is i don't have
a solution for another vehicle if i were
to do that um so i thought i'd call you
guys and pick your brand get some ideas
okay so how much could you get for the
car if you sold today
i can get about 18
100.
so about what you
owe correct
all right so that would leave you with
pretty much net zero
pretty much yeah do you have any money
in savings
uh just the uh thousand dollar emergency
fund okay and do you have any other debt
uh yes we're going baby step two so we
have uh we have another vehicle credit
card um
personal loans
okay and you have another vehicle you
said you have another car payment but
you're just looking at this one right
now
yes the other one's uh my wife's um
she's a little bit more reluctant to
sell at this point so
i'm kind of the one uh open to taking
the hit as far as getting a less
expensive vehicle what do you owe on
that one and what would it sell for
today
uh i believe we owe 23 000 on that one
and
um i haven't looked at the value in a
while but
last time i looked it up they were
offering you know a few thousand more
than than what it's worth yeah that's
why i asked i'm just wondering uh and
part of this is getting your wife on the
same page is she is she on board with
the baby steps
oh absolutely yeah we've been going
through debt um through the debt
snowball um it's just her car you know
it's a big expense and it's you know of
course it's got brand new and the
warranty and it makes her feel
safe um
so that's why i'm the one more willing
to
sell my car and kind of help speed
things up how much do you guys make matt
a year
uh we both make about 84 000. okay
um
yeah i mean it's it's a
it's a lot of car
uh when it gets to be about 50
of
your household income it starts to be a
lot um
so i would be in favor of
selling
um just to get this off your plates but
that would require
a different options right you could
pause the debt snowball save up a little
bit of cash and get what we'd call the
beater like the not so fun few thousand
dollar car
um but you're eighteen thousand dollars
lighter in debt um to do that
um if you guy what other debt do you
have you have the two cars oh what else
was that you said
uh two cars uh we have a personal loan
to about 3 500
we have about
maybe seven grand in credit cards okay
um
yeah that i mean that that that's where
i would lean if i was in your shoes and
i would really love her i understand the
feeling of
being secure and the new car the
warranty all of that but
it may give her a little bit of
ease
to go and even just look at some used
cars uh even suvs because they're not as
bad again i think people have the word
used
in their head and have a stereotype with
it but when you go and look they're not
as unsafe feeling as you would probably
imagine i mean i just feel like i just
know the weight of these cars right like
if you guys were making 150 a year and
you know that you can knock them out but
i just i just don't want to see you guys
drowning in car debt yeah when you've
got 41 000 in cars making 84 and you've
got a pile of debt it's just that's a
tough tight situation so there's gonna
be you need to make some sacrifices here
that might mean taking on some side jobs
selling your car and selling other stuff
but what you need right now is to stack
up cash quick and so
i'm gonna have a conversation with the
wife about selling this car if you can
make money from the deal and try to
clean up some of this debt because
remember you clean up those two car
payments you know have more money in
your bank every month that you can use
to attack more debt to save up more and
so maybe run some number think might
connect with her personality style but
there's gonna sacrifices need to be made
and if she's not willing to make him and
it's all on you that's to put a strain
on the relationship on your end
yeah no
it definitely can i'm i'm uh
you know i'm trying to compromise by
just me doing it um but no i and
hopefully by me and doing this it helps
kind of spur on something
um so i mean we've touched on it briefly
but it wasn't pressed too hard right now
but hopefully she comes around and is
more open to the idea you know maybe in
a few months yeah well back to your
question i'm probably gonna try to save
up
three thousand dollars and i'm gonna go
to uh reputable dealer in my area i'm
gonna look on craigslist and facebook
marketplace and whatever you do make
sure you do get inspected inspected by a
great mechanic who can you know point
out any issues because the biggest fear
everyone has rachel is what if i get a 3
000 car and i have 4 000 worth of
repairs and there's a lot of i think a
lot of it comes down to justification of
why i don't want to do the thing
um but
the truth is cars are more reliable go
get go get you an old honda an old
toyota with 200 000 miles and it's going
to get you from a to b and it's not
going to look pretty but it's going to
give you some motivation to get out of
debt the worst car you drive the more
motivation you're going to have to get
rid of this debt and so that's why i
don't love her driving this shiny new
car because it's going to get her
comfortable and you already told me
she's she's very comfortable and i want
a little more fire from her and you on
the situation clearly you're wanting to
do whatever it takes to get out
and i applaud you for that so start to
save up some cash as fast as you can if
it means pausing the snowball for a
month that's fine but i don't want you
to go well we haven't done the snowball
in six months because we're saving our
saving up for the car yeah you know and
so i just i think you're gonna need to
make some sacrifices and if she's
unwilling to do that there needs to be a
harder conversation yeah and there's
always just i mean kind of echoing what
you're saying fine the deeper you're
willing to sacrifice
whether that's time because you're
taking on an extra job whether that's
lifestyle the faster you're able to get
out of debt and honestly the faster
you're just on the other side of this
you know the sacrifices it's for a short
period of time it's not gonna it's not
gonna take too long especially if you
guys get rid of these cars you're able
to knock out the 35 000
or thirty five hundred dollar loan seven
thousand credit card i mean you can make
a lot of progress very very quickly
and then get some emergency okay you can
take a take a breath
and then go and buy another car like you
can still upgrade um that will never not
happen in your life yeah but it's just
how do we clean it up as fast as
possible to get to point a to point b as
quick as possible and
it's just you guys just have a lot of
car yeah and true security is not coming
from a 23 000 in car debt it's coming
from being debt free yeah that's the
security that i want for her thanks for
the call that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books our thanks to
you america for listening james cheers
for screen of the phones we'll be back
with you before you know it this is the
ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsey personality george
campbell joined today by ramsay
personality rachel cruz and we are here
the dream team to take your calls about
whatever you want to talk about triple
eight eight two five
five two two five corey is kicking off
this hour in fayetteville arkansas cory
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you good afternoon hey how you
doing how can we help
you're doing well thank you hey got a
question uh me and my wife are currently
on baby step six uh we're a family of
six
and living in about a twenty four
hundred square foot home if everything
comes to fruition the way we planned it
or the house paid off in about four to
five years awesome um
when we for initially bought the home
eight years ago it was just five of us
that
it just fine
yeah
that additional child kind of threw us
for a loop in many ways and uh we're
kind of running out of space and so just
wanting to
look at
we've looked at remodeling adding on
it's just with our current layout it'll
make it very difficult not really
wanting to sell we really love the
neighborhood the
uh the land we have etcetera but we're
also struggling real bad with space it's
just kind of wanting to pick you you
guys brain if you could
yeah so have you looked at the market
right now and where you would go and how
much that would cost
yeah i mean
like everywhere else we're very
fortunate with increased property value
so our homes uh worth more but of course
other homes are also selling for more as
well so i think if we were to buy what
you would set us off of our plan by
uh you know maybe additional five to
seven years and so uh not really wanting
to do that but also
like i said really hurting for space
right now yeah i mean that's a that's a
lot corey i just have three little ones
and i feel like we're just three
i have just zero and i'm like it sounds
like a lot i've got a little dog
i mean yeah corey i mean you guys are
y'all are in the baby steps
spots that baby step four through six
where we say like hey you don't have to
be gazelle intense you want to have a
goal and pay it off but you also can let
your foot off the gas and and kind of
enjoy life a little bit so you guys
we're gonna be able to pay it off in
three to five years now it'll be five to
seven years and for just the sanity and
the state of mind and the the lifestyle
value that more room can just bring
i think that's not a bad move i think
for you guys i mean as long as you
again have that that house payment's not
crazy and you get a good you have a good
down payment
all of that you could still knock it out
maybe even sooner than five to six five
to seven years but um but that quality
of life you're at the part of the baby
steps where you're able to make those
decisions and that it's not that's not a
wrong decision
yeah and as long as it's within the
parameters that you know i recommend
rachel recommends where the payment is
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay on a 50 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and i assume you'd have a big old down
payment selling this one and going into
the next one right
yeah we're i mean
currently we have anywhere from
250 000 to 315 000 in equity that's
great towards the next home yeah yeah so
i mean you're not doing a bad thing it
sounds like you were just pumped on
paying off this house and now it's like
man is setting us back but if you kind
of zoom out you are doing so much better
than the average american that you guys
should be celebrating going all right
we're gonna pay our house off in five
years and we have taken care of this
family of six
so well and we're creating the space
that we need so that none of us go crazy
i think that's a great thing and uh
you know in five years instead of three
in the grand scheme of your life you're
gonna have a paid for house that's even
bigger that's gonna cost more
to celebrate so i'm pumped for you guys
i think that's the right move obviously
the market's crazy right now so as much
patience as you want to buy as you kind
of figure out you know i don't want you
rushing into this or being forced into
it where you go well we got to put 50
over because the market's crazy make
sure you're working with a really good
real estate agent who can help you land
a deal that's right for you guys
yeah i appreciate that i guess one more
thing conversely too is in order homes
are going so fast by the time they go on
the market you have practically four
hours to make a decision which is crazy
to me to think about a uh you know 500
000 plus home to have only four hours to
make a decision or you'll lose it yeah
no it's it's stressful it is that's why
you need to know exactly what you want
when you put a payment on or i'm sorry
an offer in to be able to say okay yep
we feel comfortable when we put this off
around we feel comfortable if they take
this offer the things around it and the
terms to the agreement we feel good
about and yeah it is i mean it's it's
just it's a fast-moving market and if
you're not financially in a good spot
that's when you can make some really bad
decisions but if you guys financially
have a plan you have your money you you
know what you're looking for you guys
are on a team together you and your wife
you can you you can make a quick
decision but it it feels rushed which
i'm totally honest don't go waving
inspections and appraisals and all these
things those super important things that
you don't want to skip thanks for the
call all right josh is in atlanta
georgia josh welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
jordan rachel sure how can we
help um so i'm calling in today because
i have a girlfriend for we've been
dating for a little over a year now um
and i'm actually i guess
i would say a reluctant ramsay height
and that i've known about
dave and you all for a number of years
at any rate um
recently purchased a home and
basically
want to get gazelle like intense with
i'm on baby step two i only have a
thousand dollars
emergency fund um my question is
i recently signed up in january it's
coming up in live financial peace
university that i'll be attending um and
i wanted to see
if um i guess my question is
i'm nervous about i talk to my
girlfriend about it and she wants to do
it with me i'm about 150 thousand
dollars in debt
um plus my how
she is deferred um and i guess my
question is kind of where
her i guess when should we you know when
is it appropriate for us to sit down and
talk money and i can kind of hear dave
saying like oh well you need to get
married yesterday
um and then i guess i'm also kind of
nervous like okay well like i need to
save a ring
or
try
are you guys living together that's what
i'm calling we are not oh okay
well there's no there's no rush to get
married here and you said she's happy to
join the financial peace university
class
yes okay well then this feels more like
you're scared to tell her how much debt
you're in because of what that might do
to the relationship and how she sees you
yeah right
well i think that's going to come up
naturally in the conversation when you
attend financial peace i think it's a
great place for those conversations to
come up naturally
and uh i think you're you sound like
you're on board to pay this thing off
right now right you're on the plan
you're not ish anymore
i mean
listen i get on are you all in on these
baby steps is when you go through
financial peace are you wanting to get
rid of this hundred fifty thousand as
soon as possible
and i and i guess that's why i even
brought it up because then let her know
that you know and i think that yeah
because i want to be gazelle like which
is going to cut our lifestyle yeah
totally and i think josh and i think
just being honest with her honestly
on be honest with her honestly but to
sit down and be like listen this i hate
that this number is following me around
that you know that we talked to her
about the weight that it feels
even the embarrassment kind of the shame
and the the regret like let let her in
on all of that i mean that's human
and to say and i'm even embarrassed to
tell you but here's the reality here's
what it is and
uh let's talk through it if you don't
mean like let it be a very be honest
about it and let it just be a fluid
conversation um i mean if she flips out
and she goes well it's this is over then
hey there's the red flag you needed man
but if she's all in on this you're all
in on this it's gonna be okay yeah you
got this this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today
by rachel cruz rachel how's it going
over here
doing great you know if you've had it
with living paycheck to paycheck and are
sick and tired of constantly worrying
about money i want you to know that you
don't have to live like that anymore you
can break that cycle no matter how
you've managed money in the past or how
much debt you have you can take control
of your money you just need a plan
right now and you need the right plan
and that is financial peace university
it's helped almost 6 million people take
control of their money one step at a
time so that they can finally feel like
they have control over their lives
you'll learn how to make a budget that
actually works pay off your debts spend
and save wisely and invest in your
future in fact the average family pays
off fifty three hundred dollars in debt
and saves 2 700 in the first
90 days of the class it's a lot that's a
big turnaround and we'll walk through
the plan but it's up to you to get
started and you can decide today
that you're done stressing about money
and you're ready to take control
financial peace university is only
available through ramsey plus membership
so to get started today or to gift it to
someone you know by visiting to by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramsey solutions.com
fpu i love it i remember going through
financial peace university when i
started working here in 2013 and it was
a game changer and the fact that you can
just access all of this online for an
entire year now with all the tools and
every dollar that didn't exist back then
i feel like i'm aging myself budgeting i
had to do it on paper how to do it on
paper so that's awesome it's really is
an incredible membership make sure you
check that out and start your free trial
all right let's go to the phones this
hour grace joins us in saint george utah
grace welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much
yeah how can we help i'm excited i'm
sorry so excited to talk to you guys
okay so i
just barely discovered you guys about a
little over two weeks ago oh wow and i
kind of stuck in the butt a little bit
so i had a financial advisor
tell me that i should file some
bankruptcy and kind of thinking about it
and anyway my friends showed me your
show and i'm like oh maybe they could
have some good advice for me and
point me in the right direction i'm
grateful you called us i know absolutely
so walk us through the situation how
much debt do you have
so
it's i think it's around 70 thousand
it's all credit card debt
all credit card
no credit card okay and what's your
income
um i am i'm disabled
and
i've been to save it for about almost
three years
uh my income is about when it's 23.99
2300 and
almost
a month okay a month
all right yeah
and what led you to to this point where
you're you've got 70 000 in credit card
debt and you're talking to the financial
advisor what kind of happened
so so um
i think that's about back in may of this
year i was served
served for one credit card debt that was
about 9 600
and then recently again i was served for
um
another credit card debt
and on the first one i
i
talked with the finance of the company
that was
to me and saying hey you know what i can
pay payments and i've always planned it
to be but i just
the day says no but won't satisfy us to
do that and so
i just didn't know what to do and i just
kind of let it slide
anyway about the second one then my
son's like we've got to figure this out
we've got to figure out what we can do
because i am a single mother of eight
living at home
you say single mother of eight of eight
children
yeah and how many how many are living
with you right now all eight
all right okay
and you're taking care of them with that
2400 a month
well i do have i do get the stamps in
medical too
but um just recently since the first of
2020 they had the
um rental rental um assistant where you
could get mental assistance for coverage
yeah and place with pace families and
that's kind of what's going to save us a
little bit because they're just like
this is everything and we've already
pretty much lost a lot of everything we
had
so grace
can i ask what the nature of your
disability is you said it's been about
three years
okay
so um
my
so my first my first my husband died
and started with my mother my mother my
mother um
died like six months after i moved in
with her from cancer
and there we were evicted from our home
we moved to
to our current
lakes right now
our current city right now and we had um
so in order to survive we kind of just i
had really good credit i had i was great
and i said really good i guess we were
raised up on the fico score so that's a
whole new thing to change in my mind but
i want to
anyway so i had really good credit i i
could drag out cards if i wanted to i
mean but i came back i had was a
specialty nurse i you know i had
excellent jobs
when i moved to my current location
um i
worked
full time plus two part-time job trying
to
did we lose her grace
oh here we go okay hey there oh
you're okay
i'm so sorry you're going through all
this i mean you it's a lot crazy you
have had setback after setback after
heartbreak after heartbreak and let me
tell you the fact that you are where you
are taking care
of
your entire family i mean i'm just
inspired by you on one end and
heartbroken for you on another
and we we want to help walk you through
this and it's it's hard to do in a quick
radio call so here's what i want to do
for you grace i want to get you
connected to a financial coach who can
walk through your situation and to
answer your question
no you should not file bankruptcy right
now i believe you can get through this
you have 70 000 in credit card debt you
can clean up this mess
this is not beyond saving you are not
beyond saving and so if you hang on the
line
i'm going to have jenna pick up and
she's going to connect you with a
financial coach and we are going to pay
for that session for you you won't pay a
dime and on top of that i'm going to get
you connected to a ramsay plus
membership again we're going to pay for
that that's going to give you one year
access to financial peace university
every dollar our budgeting tool and i
want you to as you can make it through
that watch those videos
start to get a handle on a budget work
with your financial coach and they're
gonna walk
walk alongside you hold your hand and
get you out of the seventy thousand
dollars in credit card debt does that
sound good
you sure
that's great i'm so sorry you're going
through this i know grace and and what
what office is going to help you do
because you do have a lot i mean there's
a lot um a lot of dynamics here just in
your story
um but also in your financial situation
but that we're going to be able to help
map out a plan for you
very clear and this financial coach will
help you set a budget
and to know okay here are all my
expenses and and have a level of control
over your money
in the right way
that maybe you've never experienced
before grace but also i mean
um
i would also encourage you to if you i
hope you have family in the area or
a good church around you good friends
around you because
this can be a very isolating time for
you
losing your husband and taking care of
kids i can't i can't even imagine um
all that you've walked through so i want
you also to think about
yourself and the healing process and the
grieving process and and to do that
really well and and again a good
counselor or a good pastor can walk with
you through that part as well because
that's
that's almost
more important you know than the money
stuff the money stuff adds so much
stress and um hopefully we can remove
some of that by giving you that plan and
you can walk through it but there's a
lot there grace and so um thank you so
much though for for calling in and i
hope um and jenna again will pick up and
we can connect you with what you need
that's a hard situation oh man and
rachel we did an episode on the fine
print the podcast that i hosted and
the episode's called is bankruptcy a
quick fix for struggling americans and i
dug into this and we hear stories we
talk to experts i want to encourage
anyone who's going through this thinking
about it check out this episode of the
fine print uh hopefully it educates some
people and helps show them that hope is
out there and this is not the only path
and i know the financial advisor wants
this to be a shortcut to get you on your
feet but there's another way and
bankruptcy doesn't have to be it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm ramsey
personality george campbell joined today
by rachel cruz and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five crystal joins us in
bakersfield california crystal welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you i appreciate you guys having
me sure how can we help
so
um it's i'm almost embarrassed to say it
but um
so my husband and i um are
after calculating it today we have
between the both of us we have 13 000
in credit card debt
and a lot of it was accumulated from his
past job where he got paid way less than
he is now um and so we're just trying to
get out of debt and
shred our credit cards for good and just
never use them again um but and and so
we're just trying to figure out like
what what's the best way to tackle that
um you know getting rid of that debt and
i don't know i guess kind of how to
approach it sure well crystal number one
great job yeah of just looking at it i
think thank you the unknown
um
is scarier than once you bring it all
out and yes and even if 13 000 feels
overwhelming to you and you're like oh
my gosh i can't believe that at least
it's there and that takes a level of
courage to do that so so i'm just
curious how long do you feel like you
kind of lived in the dark versus just
today calculating everything how long
has this been
um
it's been
i'd say it's been probably
over a year now that we um
i i don't know i just i've kind of been
on board for a bit but my husband wasn't
so much where i was kind of like
he he wants to get out of debt but he
kind of continued to swipe his card
swipe his card and i'm like we can't no
we can't keep doing that and so so
what's changed since then what was that
was there a moment did you guys do
something
yeah so actually um
i watched a lot of y'all's youtube
videos and um i brought one up and
showed it to him and
and i think it was like a huge
eye-opener for him and i both actually
um it just
we realized so much because it's like
now that the job that we're at i i feel
like he's making such great income for
what we used to be and i told him
where's all of our money going to and
i'm like wow look at how much credit
card debt we have like we need to be
smarter with our money and we need to
get out of the set you know if we ever
want to make something of ourselves and
have a home and yeah leave something
behind for our kids that's all right so
you all felt like it was an eye-opener
yeah kind of an i had it moment like i'm
done
we see there's a different way and we're
ready we're ready to tackle so is there
any other debt crystal besides the 13
000 and credit cards
okay so there it and this one's big and
we we've been talking about just so we
have a truck right now currently
um that was a
an idiot move but we got a um a brand
new dodge last year
um it's a dodge ram and it's it's pricey
and so we looked at selling it and we
would actually if we sell it right now
we would actually make two thousand
dollars off of it for selling so if we
sell it so we kind of we're at the point
that we want to sell it but we just need
to get a vehicle that's gonna work for
us because we do need a
truck to be able to haul our horses
um and so what's the truck worth yeah
um
the truck is worth i've called different
places if if i start to do a dealer
which we don't want to do we want to go
the private way um it looks like it's
about around 62 000 currently
what's your household income yeah so
our household income uh
so are you asking yearly or monthly uh
yearly
yearly okay um i should have calculated
that that's okay what's this what is it
a monthly okay right now we're making 4
500 a month before taxes are taken out
okay
that's great yeah
that's about and actually he has done a
stay at home on
the income
myself that's about 54 000 gross
multiplied out
and you guys have a 62 000 truck
yes that's a lot of truck
yes it's a lot of truck absolutely too
much truck for us i agree that thing's
that thing's getting sold today
if i'm you guys and if you're serious
about it
we are completely serious yes
and then chris what you're gonna have to
find is a truck an old truck
not a pretty truck
the more flaws the better what they call
a farm truck here in the south
that i want
yes that you can at least hook up the
horses too so you can work because i
know that's part of part of the gig
there that of what you're doing
but but yeah yeah you guys you're going
to make some radical changes some
radical changes and
i'm so thankful you both are
willing to do that
um
because it is going to take a level of
sacrifice but you guys can do this yep
like george sell the truck the thirteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt is
there multiple credit cards or is it
just one
um it's my credit card and his we have
it's two different okay
so what
what's the two amounts on each
uh
the two amounts on each so
um i i honestly just calculated it
between the both and it was like 13
grand if i added
oh gotcha uh my husband says okay okay
so we're gonna pay his off we're gonna
sell the truck tomorrow right so the
truck's gonna be gone in our head right
and we're gonna take did you guys have
any other savings
um so we do he just got his christmas
bonus so we have
i think it's around 20 it's almost 2500
not to be exact i need it okay i need to
see that i think it's almost 2500 okay
i would take a thousand out of that and
have for your emergency your starter
emergency fund that'll be baby step one
and then once the truck is sold and you
have a couple of thousand maybe you save
up a little bit more but again
i'm telling you crystal this is not a
pretty truck you're not gonna be just
until the day is long for this thing
like you're going to get something quick
something inexpensive that you can pay
for
and then you guys are going to do a
written budget together and you're going
to start squeezing out because you guys
have been
um this is not to shame you but i just i
know it because we get these calls all
the time it's just kind of we're just
living life we're kind of just doing it
the money's going in the money's going
out we don't have any control i mean
you're gonna know like the back of your
hand exactly what every bill is
what the utilities are what you're
paying for groceries and food like you
are really really gonna tighten this up
and then you're gonna be able to look
and say okay man we are we are going out
to dinner here we're taking that money
and throwing it at the credit card what
i would have done shopping or throw it
at the credit card all of his swiping
because he's just kind of going done
with that that's all going to the credit
card i mean you really you guys are
going to buckle down and and you guys
can do this i mean that 13 000 you can
pay this off crystal you guys can do
this this is this is not a hopeless
situation but it's the behavior that i'm
most concerned about with you guys right
the idea that it was kind of we're kind
of in and out we kind of want to kind of
don't but once you got it and if you
guys commit crystal if you guys commit
18 months of your life
18 months of your life your entire
financial
trajectory will change i'm telling you
right now
i'm fired up i might sell this truck for
them if they don't i'm pumped
have you guys been through financial
peace university
i'm so sorry
no uh we have not i actually just bought
the book um through amazon and it's
supposed to be here soon um it's the
what is it the one where he's trading
the credit card the total money makeover
but
yes there you go three yeah
but no we haven't done this yeah so i
haven't been at financial peace
university yet yeah so maybe ramsay plus
were you gonna gift that yeah you know
what on top of the book since you
already got that i wanna gift you guys a
year membership to ramsey plus
while you're reading the book watch the
videos in financial peace university and
it's also going to give you access to
our premium uh every dollar budgeting
tool like rachel talked about you guys
got to get on a written plan you got to
meet weekly at this point and go where
are we spending money we got to track
this thing we're not going to go above
what we said we're going to go and this
debt is going to get paid off really
fast i mean 13 000
making 54. you guys could do this
this is not impossible but it's going to
take some sacrifice thank you guys
thank you i needed to hear that and and
actually he's going to be getting a
raise um come january he'll be making
5200 a month
and i think that's even bigger
that's right don't let the lifestyle
creep happen crystal i know it's not
going to for you i hear it in your voice
but man throw all that at the debt and
you guys get out of debt quickly yep
it's awesome hang on jenna's going to
pick up and she'll get you guys hooked
up with a ramsey plus membership call us
back when you're debt free we'd love to
hear it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
philippians 4 8.
finally brothers and sisters whatever is
true whatever is noble whatever is right
whatever is pure whatever is lovely
whatever is admirable if anything is
excellent or praiseworthy think about
such things
alexander graham bell once said
concentrate all your thoughts upon the
work in hand the sun's rays do not burn
until brought to a focus
open phones this hour the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five justin joins us in denver colorado
justin welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys longtime listener huge fan
thank you guys for having me on great to
have you how can we help today
um so i'm just kind of looking for some
financial advice
so i'm 24
have a good paying job no debt
make around
70 to 75 a year
i have about
eight months in an emergency fund um
and i try to invest around a thousand
dollars a month
into both my uh iras as well as uh s p
tracking etfs
okay so
my my main question is
i'm looking to buy a house but the
houses in my area are
way out of my price
zone and i don't want to stop investing
because i love
uh you know the personal
satisfaction of throwing money in the
market every single month
um so
i don't want to get in a position where
i'm only putting five to ten percent
down on the house but
with the prices of houses in the area
uh it's looking like that would be the
only realistic
um
you know percentage that i could put
down but then i'm also fearing that in
the next five to ten years where i could
save up to a 20
the interest rates are going to be so
high that i'll you know mathematically
lose out on the benefit of buying now
yeah i understand your fear and uh first
of all you're crushing it man way to go
24 years old 24 years old debt free
solid emergency fund you're investing
making great income
here's if i'm in your shoes here's where
how i'm thinking about this
you live in a very expensive area denver
colorado
and so your options are you've got some
options here when you're in the spot you
don't have to go zero on the retirement
you can split the difference and go i
want to lower the retirement and save up
or you can just keep investing 15
percent and be a little more patient and
save up and when it comes time for you
to find a place it's really not about
interest rate i don't want you thinking
about the fear of what's going to happen
in the future because we don't know you
just don't know it dropped to an
all-time low in 2020 i mean yeah we
don't know you don't know so unless you
have a magic ball that you're hiding
from us uh here's how i'm thinking about
it you're ready to buy a house when
you're ready to buy a house which means
you can afford it and we've got some
great parameters that make it really
clear we say hey get a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage where the payment is no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay and we want you to put 10 to 20
or more down if you do it that way then
you can afford whatever house you're
looking at if it falls into those
parameters and whenever however long it
takes to get there
you've got to be okay with that
especially if you're saying hey i really
value investing i don't want to stop
that that's great but that does mean it
may take a few more years to save up for
the house that you want in denver
colorado now that doesn't mean you're
stuck you can move i don't know what you
do for work maybe one day you don't live
in denver and there's a lower cost of
living area and you can afford a house
there uh your income will go up over
time probably
and you can save up even more
and so there are things that you can do
to kind of counteract this but you're 24
there's no rule that says you have to
have a home at 24. and i understand you
feel like are you do you feel like
you're wasting money on rent right now
oh yeah it hurts yeah yeah i'm hanging
around
300 a month it is just you know just
going to a sunk cost it definitely hurts
yeah which it which totally understands
but
like george said after those parameters
are kind of met around the home buying
process
that's when the home really is a gift
and it's like okay i can enjoy this
before that if you
go in too quickly you'll realize okay
the cost of a house is expensive the
heating and air goes out i got to
replace this i got to replace that i got
to do the yard work uh the closing costs
i mean there's just so much
so many fees so much that goes into
owning a home
um so you want to factor that into to
give yourself just a little bit of that
like breathing room of okay i'm renting
but it's not i mean people think like oh
renting is just throwing your money away
which i get i understand
but also if you get yourself in a really
bad situation in a home that's gonna be
far worse financially than renting for
24 more months so take your time justin
you're doing great you're doing great
and i would run the numbers it sounds
like you're very on top of what's going
on but just run the numbers and say okay
what if i paused investing for 24 months
because you can you have plenty of time
to invest okay
and say yeah what if i focused all my my
energy on this house and how fast could
i be or what george said split the
difference then how long would it take
to save up for a down payment or say
uh you know what what if i just throw a
bunch of invest and i don't think about
this for another year and i come back
around to it right you have you have
options uh but you're gonna do great
justin you're you're incredible 24 years
old very sharp he's going to be a
multi-millionaire either way it's just
whatever path you want to take to get
there thanks for the question and we do
have a great episode of the fine print
featuring my friend rachel cruz if you
want to check that out you can go to
fineprintpodcast.com and it's called is
now the worst time to buy a house and me
and rachel have this conversation i talk
with experts we hear real stories and it
really helps give people a little bit of
pause and go just breathe yes okay
here's what's going on in the market
here's what i need to know here's how i
know if i'm ready to jump into that
that's right so thanks for the question
all right aaron joins us down the road
here in nashville tennessee erin welcome
to the ramsey show
hey thank you for taking my call sure
how can we help
yeah so um me and my wife are in baby
step um four and five
and over the past year my job wasn't too
stable so my wife and i went to saving
mode
fast forward to today my got a new job
it's very stable but we have about 80 to
90 thousand dollars above our emergency
fund sitting in a savings account
and we have a dilemma on what to do um
my wife wants to fully fund my uh son's
college fund well i think it'd be better
to kind of put it all on the house and
get that paid off sooner and just
continue to put monthly into our um
since college and see what you guys
thought so you have one one kid
yes just one kid he's uh four and a half
four
that's adorable all right what's on the
mortgage i already know what i would say
um 155 000. 155 on the mortgage okay i'm
gonna let rachel say hers but i will
answer honestly after she's done we'll
see if it lines up this is exciting oh
yeah aaron i i love your wife's hearts
and i appreciate
her um
willingness to throw money at the
college fund i would still put some
money in there but i would throw a big
old chunk of this at the house if not
all of it he's four now if he was
15 this would probably be a totally
different discussion but you guys are
gonna have plenty of time if you think
about what you would pay in a mortgage
and put that in the college fund every
month you know like with a paid for
house with no risk all of it it's going
to work out so mine would be the house
george i can't wait to hear stole the
words you are going to say right out of
my mouth stole my thunder i am 100 with
rachel on this and i always ask the age
because i got to know do you have time
for this money to sit there and grow and
you've got 14 years to save for a thing
that may or may not happen and we don't
know what college they'll go to and if
they'll get scholarships what college is
going to look like yeah in 10 years but
here's what we do know you've got a big
old mortgage payment that you could get
rid of and you could be over halfway
done with it with the remaining balance
today
and so that's what i'm doing how's that
feeling
that that makes perfect sense tell your
wife i'm for her though in life i was
disagreeing with her
yeah and it's not there's no like crazy
right or wrong here but right i like to
look at the time frames and go all right
the kids for they've got a long way to
go yeah they're probably going to be
okay and guess what once you have that
house paid for in a few years now we can
really save up for college absolutely
and if it's looking like they want to go
to this school and we want to pay cash
for it you'll be able to do that because
you haven't had a mortgage payment in a
decade and what a great job erin i mean
the idea of even just with the
uncertainty of everything that happened
his job was uncertain so they kind of
just paused
buckle down just put some cash away
what that does i mean instead of just
just living and just not knowing what's
going on i mean to really focus
and have money money's not the end all
be all but it gives you options it gives
you the ability to say okay now what do
we want to do with this
um it's a powerful thing so aaron great
job to you and your wife you guys were
really disciplined in a really tough
tough year so great job yeah fun hour
rachel i know george thanks for hosting
with me i loved it it's great to be in
the in the pilot's chair with you this
is good times that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books our thanks to
james childs our producer jenna sears
screen on the phones today and you
america we can't do the show without
amazing listeners like you and we're
grateful you joined us today this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you